foreign
we're talking about glasses those are
those work dude oh thanks man do you are
those uh regularly like you bust those
out or special occasions or yeah I wear
these These are actually kind of
disguised glasses I'll wear them like if
I'm in the airport or somewhere uh to
kind of be a little more Incognito I
guess you know I mean I
[Music]
I think they have that effect I think
you know I just think they're they look
they look good they're good glasses what
do you think I don't think I look over
them like who the [__] is that guy I
think oh yeah I think that's the ovonne
yeah maybe yeah maybe I gotta get it get
them tinted or something but um yeah
because just to be clear you did say I
have some sunglasses yeah and uh those
are not
oh you wear these I'll wear them in the
sun dude it sucks
oh those suck oh yeah
I would say yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
put them on a baby have you have you
explored why you think they suck as
sunglasses no I haven't really gotten
into it but I just it's not I think a
lot of it is more me pretending that
they work yeah yeah I could see that you
ever have a sister's boyfriend punk you
out
or like try to hurt you I did no I had
one time where you know I was always
kind of a smart ass yeah I guess so I'm
like oh yeah how's the how's the season
going you guys doing all right he was
he's an athlete he's an athlete he's
thinking that I'm I guess like I I'm
either mocking him or talking to him
like an older man would yeah and he was
like he just kind of looked cleaned the
gun the whole time
that's for me popping on the couch the
couches against the wall it's usually
but everyone is out of the room
like they it was just me and him for a
second and then he just he was like he
just looked at me and just real quick
just punch me in the stomach yeah
he was just taking it I I get it in a in
a sense that that he was like why is
this kid that's like a couple years
younger than me being like because I was
like and I kind of like I sat like on
the arm of the couch oh yeah I was like
how's it going man yeah like and I think
he was like how you doing champ I think
he was like he was waiting he was
thinking I was setting it up I don't
think I said something particularly but
he he thought I was like any everything
going on right there and then he just
went like back like that and I was like
like that I cried dude I went in the
other room and cried like so he couldn't
see me but I totally cried and then now
it feels like it's almost like it's
abnormal if you don't believe that
something is potentially out there think
about their sledgehammers when they show
up oh wow if they're eight to ten feet
tall
[Music]
but that is allegedly what it looked
like they did a sketch you know from the
kids uh memory you know I'm able to find
serial killers able to find people that
steal things and also a large oversized
eyes put them in cheers wrapped behind
the backs of their heads and [__] like
yeah Frozen big dicks huge dicks and
that guy at that conference breathing
out of his ears yeah I mean there's been
so much [__] Tom it's only a matter of
time I can't wait to see what sports
they play you know I can't wait for us
to cover what sports they play if they
come into the NFL they hey we need to
Institute the head hunting rules again
yeah and you know what I mean what do
you think God by the way are they gonna
finally honor that guy that that the
coordinator the one who was like hunt
for their heads
he's back yeah he's back everybody just
salute you sir that is that is the
message I mean come on you've played
defense h
it's like a coach that's like let's try
to [__] these mothers that's who you
want to play for that's that's the coach
that I go I'm gonna sacrifice myself for
this guy I want the message should be
eliminate the enemy and I I just I just
feel like they should they should do a
special uh Hall of Fame induction
that is
unbelievable I saw a lady last night
with the craziest tits really good or
bad a risque it was just you know when
there's so there they were such
outrageous hits like she was hot and
they were enormous and she was wearing
the uh you know the like top that goes
here but the top was just above the
nipples so I mean just just yeah just a
covering like you could almost see the
beginning of a nipple and they were like
here and then she has this little body
and party just wants to go like hey
just why don't you just take a moment in
the room and just go hey everybody
get used to them yeah like why are we
going to pretend like we're gazing past
right yeah like I kept having to pretend
I was like what's what's that noise over
there I wasn't looking at a noise
looking at your crazy tits tits are
insane yeah is that an owl yeah and then
guys are like talking to me about other
things I go we're going to talk about
her tits first like what are you doing
and they're like oh yeah I'm like what
do you think we're gonna like gloss over
this like her tits are out she has huge
tits that are out in the room
yeah it is weird not to just bring it up
it's like when someone's in a wheelchair
and they try to pretend they're not
going to be like God please what's the
most racist thing that's happened to you
in Iowa uh a guy after a show bought me
a beer and told me I'm funny for oh
wow that is I don't even know what that
is still it's still a compliment it is
it is
like you know what I mean it's not a
cool way to say it but it's still
positive
like there's people thinking that here
you know I'm just saying
[Music]
[Applause]
I've run into you actually a few times
over the last few years even on tour
you've like I've you've popped up at
shows that I was at you remember we've
run into each episode of Kenny got me a
ticket to see you at the MSG during the
911 thing and you were incredible thank
you I knew you
I mean I was
amazed when jonster went up to you
begging to talk to you and whether his
kids and everything so I was so happy to
see that it was a fun night that was a
really fun night and it was so fun to
see you and um I had I was talking about
I go my friend my friend really wants a
picture my high school friend and
because my buddy of mine from high
school was at that show right right
right and then they're like okay and
then that person started to go up to you
though I guess your friend I go that's
not my friend that guy's Asian
let's be honest this is a problem
everywhere yeah
I was at uh one of the Boston venues and
they told me after the show they're like
you know sometimes they'll tell me you
know we had three injections or 12 which
like you know they'll tell me that after
the show
like yeah we had a eject the guy from
the upper balcony he just uh like
squatted forward and pissed on the floor
so he didn't want to get up so they're
like they're just everybody's like what
is this
and then everyone's like it's this guy
who's pissing in the seat Jesus Christ
people are [__] animals they're
animals yeah oh my God one other venue
they said that a guy went he left the
aisle and then just went to the corner
like just pissed in the corner of the
theater and they're like what are you
doing he just didn't he was like I don't
want to go out and miss the show
don't forget I'm going to Vegas and you
told me to tell you when oh yeah yeah
just pick a weekend I'll tell you I'll
send you to Vegas too
I love you too I miss you okay okay
bye mom
well hopefully this will be our last
year and we have to do this anymore
um
have you ever played acoustic guitar at
a party no no now I'm insulted this is
[__] [__] I thought there was a
little bit of respect
some storms out
yeah
I stepped on one I don't think I've ever
played one I just did Ayahuasca and uh
did you really yeah that's nice the
baked the chocolate like the cookies you
have to go through the vomiting diarrhea
they they cook it down into these try it
doesn't taste good yeah but it's way
better than have like the authentic
version and I'm so stupid that I
everyone I've told they're like what are
you like I ate it at night right before
I was like I'll eat it before bed I'm
gonna help me go to bed I was just like
wanting to feel a buzz and then I was
like wait in bed I was like
it was too strong just Ayahuasca just on
a whim yeah like 11 o'clock at night I
thought you were like with a shaman like
nah not having a guidance no here's the
thing the shaman gave it sent it to me
with instructions I didn't read them I
didn't look I read them the next day and
they were like go into this with
intention and like you know I just ate
it and I was just in bed like what the
[__] I need to I shouldn't be on tour
this much
lead is a good rule though don't [__]
your your friend I even had it in
college a guy who I like we were friends
and then we kind of like weren't that
and his ex came over to my place one
night and just put it on me like put it
fully on me and I was 20 years old sure
but I'm saying it wasn't like I think I
could like she just went for it and I
said no because he's my friend it's a
great because I even and he's like I
didn't even like him
anymore and I was like I I go this would
be two it would be too too much to deal
with another guy had the same
opportunity with the same girl and did
and it you know where's that guy I want
to do that guy's podcast yeah yes let me
tell you something Mrs you're really
dabbling in uh oh yeah this is a hot
topic for you guys yeah yeah yeah but he
[__] your ex sure
endor's dating for seven years oh that
all right well but that has turned into
something though sure yeah him and my
girl dated for a couple of months casual
whatever okay sorry they hooked up or
anything
you son of a [__] and then you know we
fell in love and we've been together
ever since I mean but that's sure it's
not the same example sure she was just
gonna let me put it in her ass
I swear I've known this guy for 20 years
and we do he he's always been like you
know I just I wasn't a big dater and
then we turn on these mics and he's like
this
I just told a story about how I didn't
do something it's true yeah I feel like
it counts though getting proposition you
couldn't even tell me what what would
the story have been one time
this beautiful girl with the tightest
little hole
threw it at me begging for it I would
like to have a kid because I think they
it would be funny
I think kids are very funny this is true
I would like to maximize that in my life
and I think at a certain point when I'm
40 I'm gonna need a reboot to be my
little material it's so funny they're
very funny Yes mine they're also they
they're manipulative much earlier than
you think like in your mind when you
haven't had kids or like even when
they're babies you're like oh they'll be
like conniving it I don't know you go
like 13 yeah yeah dude my four-year-old
he comes up to me and he goes
you know
mom's a lot more fun than you
okay thanks and he goes yeah she just
like takes us some more fun places does
a lot more things that are fun than you
do and I go
okay thanks for telling me and then he
goes uh will you give me a scooter
for my birthday and I go well
I mean you just told me
that Mom is more and then you ask me
that and he he leans over and he goes
you're more fun than Mom oh my God he
goes now will you get me and I was like
I was like I don't believe you we both
know you could be more fun with that but
it was like a you know it was like so
calculated yeah he's like did you like
that he slayed you a hundo he was like
yeah let's make this he was greasing you
up yeah that's amazing they've been
doing that for Wow I'll be like uh you
know no more iPad to the older one
he's seven and then he'll be like if I
give you like a big he has a deep voice
he goes what if I give you like some
kisses and hug you is he black yeah
I go no dude
I get an iPad I go no it's not about
kisses and hugs bro I was at a bar in
L.A and it was it was dark it was like a
Cool vibe and this girl approached me
again I'm like 22 or 23 years old
approached me and was very forward and
like flirty and asked for my for my
number right which I was like wow that's
pretty like bold and you know it was
cool the way she did it so I was like
yeah I gave her my number she called me
the next day
and was like
just you know talking about what do you
want you know you want to do something
this Friday and I was like sure so I go
to pick her up and I was like damn it
was dark in that bar you know like it's
not
it's just wild so I was immediately like
the [__] do I do so I she was like let's
go to this party let's go to this bar
let's go you know and I'm like I'm
trying to do the exit strategy right I'm
trying not to be like
you know I'm not gonna leave her on the
405 I want to but I'm not going to so I
just kind of like you know I drive and I
just kind of shut down like you don't
want to keep
um even if you find the person cool if
you're like this is not going to go
anywhere you don't want to like keep
engaging like right making her laugh or
like I'm having like you don't want to
let her think you're having a good time
exactly so the only way thing I did was
just kind of like shut down like I just
turned into an Uber driver I was like um
okay so blast the music so she can't
speak yeah I was like you know the voice
is the best part about you and it's not
great so I um yeah when I find you know
I did the the spots it was somebody had
a party and then I take her back to her
place and I was like well at least you
know I got here the whole thing was like
just get back to dropping her off yeah
and then she was like do you want to
come up I was like nope and then
Margo hard no and and then she uh she
leaned in to kiss and I gave her my
cheek oh
oh it's not misleading that's that's a
very clear message and then that's a
direct I'm not interested yeah exactly
which I wanted her to know right so uh I
did that and then I was like you know
you don't owe me for gas just get the
yeah so
that joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out